we make way for Ricky Fowler not only a
great golfer but the executive producer
of basketball or nothing it's a six part
documentation boys high school
basketball team which just premiered
Friday on Netflix and ricky joins us now
how did you get involved in this
docu-series well projects with workshops
they've helped me shoot a few things and
helped out with some content and so when
the project came about and they saw the
opportunity to pitch it to me be
involved with by Navajo community being
that in Coronado my Grandmamma other
side is full Navajo so it was a great
fit and a way to bring you know a little
bit of Navajo spotlight to the rest of
the world I'm assuming you've been to
reservations before yeah it had been a
while back to the Navajo Reservation so
it was it was pretty cool to make a stop
in Chile and spend some time with the
team and the coaches and the staff and
the kids so it was a that was special
but really kind of reliving it through
you know the show finally coming out and
that's like it was it was kind of cool
to see all that
how important is sports to them sports
is is a big part of life you know
there's there's a lot of hardships with
type 2 diabetes that they want but
diabetes in general and obesity so
sports is a way especially when the
younger generation is able to get
involved in sports any of them across
the board that's a huge help for their
lifestyle and you can watch this doc you
said
[Music]
who was your favorite team growing up
you were you you were born in California
live in Florida but I'm curious you got
a football team you know I really wasn't
huge exactly in the didn't have a
specific football team or a whole team
growing up I always loved sports I love
playing sports my main background in
action sports other than golf so I grew
up riding racing dirt bike
so I still follow supercross motocross a
bunch and I've been lucky enough now
where I've been able to meet all the
different athletes so I mean I would say
I have more guys that I follow through
the NFL and and in the NBA and stuff
like that but yeah I didn't really have
a team grown up more geeked-out meeting
Tom Brady or Dave Mirra I got to spend
you know a little bit of time with with
Dave through the ears
I've been told some time with Tom and
play some golf for them to very
well-respected athletes but when you
play golf with Brady at what point does
he stop being Tom Brady and he's just
Tom you're playing with a place and you
can you can see the constant side
throughout their point like I said he's
competitive it doesn't matter what we're
playing for he's on it and he's in it
who's more competitive Michael Jordan or
Brady when you play ooh that would I
would need to see them in a team game
matchup where Tom and MJ are on opposite
teams that could get pretty heated I
would have to put them and I'd have to
put them on the same page they're
they're two of obviously the greatest at
what they did and Tom still does which
is pretty impressive he's he's had the
career that he's had and it and it's
still rolling
but do famous people ask for golf
lessons they do for sure I would say Tom
Tom's a little bit more of walnuts we'll
ask him and is it open to some pointers
MJ's kind of got his his stuff together
he he's been playing I think a lot
longer and then obviously being a little
bit more free time on his hands he kind
of owns what he has he has you know a
little bit of an aura
unorthodox swing but he's got a damn
good short game I'll tell you that yeah
I think it would be fun to see that and
and you know Tiger once told me you know
if we play golf
and I say how much we plan for and he
said whatever makes you nervous I think
Jordan uses that line too did he use it
on you
oh yeah no he uses it we have our kind
of standard game now so it's nothing
that's kind of nervous feeling we go out
and enjoy it and love beating up on each
other but that's it that is definitely
his standard line when it comes to
someone new joining the game yeah they
like to say that then you get up but you
know I don't know what's going to what
amount would make you nervous oh there's
always an amount no I don't it is it's
obviously different when you're playing
for your own money and having to whip
out the cash on anything it's great
enough what's the most money you've ever
seen change hands you don't have to do
names most money that you were ever
involved in or you saw um well for
myself I haven't I haven't been involved
in a whole lot I mean it's playing for
maybe a thousand couple thousand here
they're friendly games the most I've
seen thrown around I haven't been in any
of those big games and maybe seen five
or ten shows nothing crazy I try and I
stay away from those if anything I like
might like I said the good friendly game
go have fun
it's it's enough to put a little dent
there and have bragging rights what's
your favorite Tiger Woods story favorite
tiger well there's fried some that
should remain we definitely I mean
definitely just yeah we've had a good
time with PETA over the last say five
years or so from him until his injuries
to kind of his comeback story
just kind of trying to hater a little X
as possible trying to trying to you know
keep them down with us keep them uh
level-headed it's not always working
though they say you give him grief just
to humble him a little bit and you know
keep him on your level well I mean he's
either a whole different level it's just
it's fun to you know have someone that
is is now a good friend someone that we
looked up to growing up and basically
idolized and we just have a blast being
voice together do golf on vacation Oh
always
I love playing but do you go out like
with ugly plaid shorts and a cigar and
those kind of things you know like we do
it depends on the occasion but yes if
it's Baker's day they may not be assured
it might just be board shorts
there could be drinks there could be
cigar if it's getting ready for a
tournament I think it's gonna be a
little bit more put together and
practice oriented yeah but if I got and
I think Justin Thomas talked about this
I said if there were beers involved if
we were gonna who's a one-seed if if
we're playing golf with beers I you know
I I've heard a few talks about this and
it puts me pretty high up there I feel
like I do a good job of managing my
level there's others I may not have to
speak about that may not do as good of a
job on us to put Dustin Johnson up there
as well meaning he just flat-out play
and drink hey if the occasion calls for
it yes he can it doesn't matter the
situation he's ready to ready to go
speech said he's pretty good I had my
doubts mmm yeah I'm gonna side with you
on that
[Laughter]
have you ever I was thinking if you did
a twins where it's like you and Brooks
koepka are you and Dustin Johnson or you
know you had Arnold Schwarzenegger and
Danny
you know not that you're that small but
Brooks is so big and Dustin Johnson is
so big and like you look at some of
these guys and you go they should be
playing another sport than golf yeah I'm
just I'm glad that it's not a contact
sport but no you know that's what's the
beauty of golf is it doesn't matter you
know what you look like how big you are
it's you know who can who can play the
best you know that week that day and you
know it's a little different from I'm
never gonna play or was never gonna play
in the NBA or the NFL I mean size does
come into play and you know other sports
but you know size can help in golf but
it's not a determining factor yeah it's
it's interesting I played golf with
Eddie Georgia former NFL running back
and he won the Heisman Trophy and he
looked at me cuz I was hitting it
further than he was not that I hit it
far but he couldn't he so he would swing
harder and I kept saying to him Eddie
you're not gonna hit it further than me
by doing that he couldn't understand the
science of it and it drove him crazy he
just thought hey I'm 6 3 you know 230
pounds and I'm an athlete I should be
able to hit it past this you know
spindly looking guy but it doesn't it
doesn't work that I mean look at Justin
you know yeah Thomas is not a big guy or
Charles Howell the third that's what's
amazing when people go weight he weighs
150 pounds and he hits it that far and I
go yeah that's golf crazy yes exactly I
mean you know I would say myself and JT
were up there so the longest pound for
pound and a lot of people come up to us
whether it's programs or playing at all
or what it's you know how do you guys it
is so far well it's just it comes down
to how you're able to use your body
efficiently you look at somewhat like a
DJ it looks very effortless and it
creates a lot of speed you know size and
and your height can help produce more
speed but if you don't know how to use
it it doesn't matter how big you are
can't say enough good things about this
this show on Netflix it's a docu-series
it's called basketball or nothing Rickie
Fowler's an executive producer of this
Navajo Nation's boys high school
basketball team it premiered Friday on
Netflix Ricky great to talk to you and
good luck on the upcoming rest of the
season we appreciate your time yeah
thanks for having me damn pretty good
that's no Ricky Fowler for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]